was a beautiful look just had a little
too much spin on that pass
didn't allow for morris to grab it
cleanly
my goodness
goodness
two blazer guards have been unstoppable
lillard from way downtown
lillard with a great job splitting his
draymond green did not get high enough
on that pick with iguodala
and a beautiful move putting draymond
green on the ground and the ball in the
hoop
they've already given up 12 points in
the paint they got to stop that
okay portland's not a team that can
score the ball well in the paint you
can't make it easy
[Applause]
on the pass every once in a while dame
will surprise you with one of those
because we just think of him as a
shooter we think about the crafty handle
but every once in a while he'll go down
the lane and he will just throw it down
long ball by dame coming up with felt it
on him
step back three-pointer is up
[Applause]
again
and it's because the lakers can't have
that much spacing you know why they
don't have many three-point shooters
like that like that damien lillard let
dave
have his time but after a missed free
throw
lillard nails afraid crowd oohs is his
crossover got mckinney to fall it was a
beautiful look just had a little too
much
spin on that pass didn't allow for
morris to grab it
cleanly my goodness
goodness i mean if katie would draw
right there that that would be
considered a four point shot in that
three-on-three league
and this man right here is just in his
elements a chance to send the thunder
home
lillard long
[Applause]
[Music]
what up it's your boy adam lefkow did
you like that content i know you like
that content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleach report